JAMES GRIME: Yeah, we're doing
sexy maths today, right?
So we're talking about
sexy primes.
Well, I'm not really qualified
to talk about sexiness.
I've come dressed as a salsa
teacher tonight.
So hooray.
But I am qualified to talk
about prime numbers.
Fortunately for me, though, in
this case, sexy means another
word for six.
So it's sixy primes.
That's what we're going to do.
Let's be honest.
The reason we're doing this
video is because it has a
funny name.
But let's see what
a sixy prime is.
OK.
So a sixy prime--
or two primes, actually,
that differ by 6.
So if I pick 5--
that's a prime number--
and 11, those are two prime
numbers, and the
difference is 6.
So they called sexy primes.
We can pick another example.
Let's pick 7, and
let's add on 6.
I get 13.
So a slightly bigger
one, then.
Let's pick 251.
That is a prime number.
And let's add on 6,
and we'll get 257.
Let's pick some sexy triplets.
Yeah, yeah.
It's getting more exciting
all the time, isn't it?
This is 5, 11, and 17.
So those are three prime
numbers, difference of six
between them.
These are sexy triplets.
Another one might be--
let's pick this.
I picked that one on purpose
so I could use it again.
251, 257--
let's add on 6 again,
and I get 263.
All right, sexy quadruplets.
Let's pick 5, 11, 17, and
add on 6 again, 23.
Those are all prime numbers,
and they are sexy.
Sexy quintuplet.
You're absolutely right.
5, 11, 17, 23, 29.
Those are all prime numbers, and
that's a sexy quintuplet.
BRADY HARAN: That's not going
to the next level,
that one, is it?
DR. JAMES GRIME: No, it isn't
going to go to the next level.
You're right.
If I add on 6 again, I get 35,
which is divided by 5.
It's not a prime number.
And in fact, that one is the
only sexy quintuplet.
That is the only one
that exists.
And I can prove to you that it's
the only one that exists.
Can I?
Imagine you're going to
pick a quintuplet.
We'll call the first
one a, OK?
And the next one, well, you
add on 6, don't you?
a plus 6.
So the next one is a plus 12.
And the next one is a plus 18.
And the next one is a plus 24.
These are my sexy quintuplets.
Now, these are all
prime numbers.
Now, if you had a remainder of
0 when you divide by 5, that
means it's a multiple of 5.
Do you remember that
from school?
When you divide by 5, a
remainder of 0 means it's a
multiple of 5.
If you had a remainder of 5 or
10 or 15, that's another way
of saying it's a
multiple of 5.
If a has a remainder of 0, then
it's a multiple of 5, so
5 would work.
And we know what this is then.
If this is 5, we get
11, 17, 23, 29.
If it's a different multiple
of 5, though, if it's 10 or
15, it's not a prime, right?
So we can get rid of that.
What about when you divide by
5, you get 1 left over?
By which I mean, what
if it was 11, right?
You divide by 5, and you have 1
left over, a remainder of 1.
If that was true, this one
over here would have a
remainder of 25.
And if it has a remainder of
25, it's a multiple of 5.
So it's not a prime.
We can keep going.
If that has a remainder 2, that
has a remainder 20, and
it's a multiple of 5.
It's not prime.
If that has remainder 3,
that has remainder 15.
It's a multiple of 5.
It's not prime.
If that has remainder 4,
that has remainder 10.
It's a multiple of 5.
It's not prime.
It can only work if the first
number had a remainder of 0,
and that only works if it's 5.
I've got something else
about sexy primes.
So sexy primes, again, it's
a funny name, right?
So they have a difference
of 6.
There's a similar idea with
other prime numbers, though.
If they differ by 2, they're
called twin primes.
If they differ by 4, they're
called cousin primes.
We have missed out 3's though,
if they have a
difference of 3.
I don't think they
have a name.
We'll call them triplet
primes.
Let's call them that.
But if you think about it, if
they're different by 3, one of
them has to be even if they're
different by 3.
Now, there's only one
even prime number.
It's 2.
So the only triplet prime
will 2 and 5.
That's the only one.
But we can keep going.
If they have a difference
of 5, what are we
going to call them?
Quincy primes.
Quincy--
that reminds me of Quincy
solving crimes on a boat.
So if they have a difference
of 5, same reason though.
They have to have one
of them even.
So 2 and 7 are going to
be Quincy primes.
If you keep going, we've talked
about sexy primes.
So let's talk about
difference of 7.
That's going to be a
septic prime, which
doesn't sound very nice.
Septic prime.
One of them has to
be even, so 2.
Add on 7, you get 9,
which isn't prime.
There aren't any
septic primes.
We've shown there's
no septic primes.
If you keep going, I think
the next one's
the best one, though.
Difference of 8.
What do you think that's
going to be called?
Octimus Prime!
I think we can get a difference
of 8, yeah.
Let's try it.
Let's have 3 and 11.
BRADY HARAN: And 19.
JAMES GRIME: There you go.
We've got an Octimus
Prime triplet.
Hooray!
2 and 11 will be non,
noni, noni--
nonlet.
BRADY HARAN: But surely
it goes forever.
Lookit, we've got a whole
industry to make here.
JAMES GRIME: I think the viewers
are going to have fun
making up their own names now.
7 times 8 divide by 2.
That's 56 divided by 2.
How many--
how many arrows do you want?
So the next one, let's
say we did 3--
Same thing.
--to the power of,
to the power of--
oh, arrow, arrow, arrow--
Divide by 2--
--or whatever you want
to call this.
--and that will give you the
third perfect number for--